can we still Mount the case for some
level of transparency and openness maybe
open sourcing
so the case could be that because gpt4
is not close to AGI if that's the case
that this does allow open sourcing
you're being open about the architecture
being transparent about maybe research
and investigation of how the thing works
of all the different aspects of it of
its behavior of its structure of of its
training processes if the data was
trained on everything like that that
allows us to gain a lot of insights
about alignment about the alignment
problem to do really good AI Safety
Research while the system is not too
powerful can you make that case that it
could be a resource I do not believe in
the practice of Steel Manning there's
something to be said for trying to pass
the ideological Turing test where you
describe
your opponent's position uh the disagree
disagreeing person's position well
enough that somebody cannot tell the
difference between your description and
their description
but steel Manning no like okay well this
is where you and I disagree here that's
interesting why don't you believe in
steel Manning I do not want okay so for
one thing if somebody's trying to
understand me I do not want them steel
Manning my position I want them to
describe to to like try to describe my
position the way I would describe it not
what they think is an improvement
well I I think that is what
the steel Manning is is the most
charitable interpretation
I I don't want to be interpreted
charitably I want them to understand
what I'm actually saying if they go off
into the land of charitable
interpretations they're like often their
land of like
the thing the stuff they're imagining
and not trying to understand my own
Viewpoint anymore well I'll put it
differently then just to push on this
point I would say it is restating what I
think you understand
under the empathetic assumption that
Eliezer is brilliant
and have honestly and rigorously thought
about the point he has made right so if
there's two possible interpretations of
what I'm saying and one interpretation
is really stupid and whack and doesn't
sound like me and doesn't fit with the
rest of what I've been saying and what
interpretation you know sounds like some
like something a reasonable person who
believes the rest of what I believe
would also say go with the second
interpretation that's steel Manning
that's that's a good guess
if on the other hand you like there's
like
something that sounds completely whack
and something that sounds like a little
less completely whack but you don't see
why I would believe in it doesn't fit
with the other stuff I say but you know
that sounds like less whack and you can
like sort of see you could like maybe
argue it then you probably have not
understood it see okay I'm gonna this is
fun because I'm gonna Linger on this you
know you wrote a brilliant blog post AJ
I ruined a list of lethalities right and
it was a bunch of different points and I
would say that some of the points are
bigger and more powerful than others
if you were to sort them you probably
could you personally and to me steel
Manning means like going through the
different arguments and finding the ones
that are really the most like
powerful if people like tldr
like what should you be most concerned
about and bringing that up in a strong
uh compelling eloquent way these are the
points that elieza would make to to make
the case in this case that hey it's
going to kill all of us but that that
that's what steel Manning is presenting
it in a really nice way the summary of
my best understanding of your
perspective that because to me there's a
sea of possible presentations of your
perspective and steel Manning is doing
your best to do the best one in that sea
of different perspectives do you believe
it
don't believe in what like these things
that you would be presenting as like the
strongest version of my perspective do
you believe what you would be presenting
do you think it's true
I I'm a big proponent of empathy when I
see the perspective of a person
there is a part of me that believes it
if I understand it and you have
especially in political discourse in
geopolitics I've been hearing a lot of
different perspectives on the world
and I hold my own opinions but I also
speak to a lot of people that have a
very different life experience and a
very different set of beliefs and I
think there has to be epistemic humility
in
in stating what is true so when I
empathize with another person's
perspective there is a sense in which I
believe it is true
I I think probabilistically I would say
in the way you think do you bet money on
it
um do you do you bet money on their
beliefs when you believe them
are we allowed to do probability
sure you can State a probability of that
yes there's there's a loose there's a
probability there's a there's a
probability and I think empathy is
allocating a non-zero probability to
believe
in some sense for time
if you've got someone on your show who
believes in the abrahamic deity
classical style somebody on the show
who's a young Earth creationist do you
say I put a probability on it and that's
my empathy
when you reduce beliefs into
probabilities it starts to get you know
we can even just go to Flat Earth is the
earth flat
because I think it's a little more
difficult nowadays to find people who
believe that unironically but
fortunately
I think well it's hard to know an ironic
yeah
from ironic uh but I think there's quite
a lot of people that believe that yeah
it's
there's a space of argument where you're
operating in rationally in the space of
ideas but then there's also
a kind of discourse where you're
operating in the space of
subjective experiences and life
experiences like
I think what it means to be human is
more than just
searching for truth
it's just operating of what is true and
what is not true I think there has to be
deep humility that we humans are very
limited in our ability to understand
what is true
so what probabilities do you assign to
the young Earth's creationists beliefs
then
I think I have to give non-zero out of
your humility yeah but like
three
I think I would uh it would be
irresponsible for me to give a number
because the The Listener the way the
human mind works
we're not good at hearing the
probabilities
right you hear three what is what is
three exactly right they're going to
hear they're going to like well there's
only three probabilities I feel like
zero fifty percent and a hundred percent
in the human mind or something like this
right well zero forty percent and a
hundred percent is a bit closer to it
based on what happens to chat GPT after
you RL H effort to speak Humanities this
is brilliant uh yeah this is really
interesting I didn't I didn't know those
negative side effects of rlhf that's
fascinating but uh just to uh return to
the
open AI close there also like quick
disclaimer I'm doing all this for memory
I'm not pulling out my phone to look it
up it is entirely possible that the
things I'm saying are wrong so thank you
for the disclaimer so uh uh and thank
you for
what being willing to be wrong
that's beautiful to hear
I think being willing to be wrong is a
sign of a person who's done a lot of
thinking about this world and has been
humbled by the mystery and the
complexity of this world and I think
a lot of us are resistant to admitting
we're wrong because it hurts it hurts
personally
it hurts especially when you're a public
human it hurts publicly because people
uh
people point out every time you're wrong
like look you change your mind you're
hypocrite you're uh an idiot whatever
whatever they want to say oh I block
those people and then I never hear from
them again on Twitter
well the point is uh the point is to not
let that pressure public pressure affect
your mind and be willing to be in the
privacy of your mind
to contemplate
the possibility that you're wrong and
the possibility that you're wrong about
the most fundamental things you believe
like people who believe in a particular
God people who believe that their nation
is the greatest nation on Earth but all
those kinds of beliefs that Accord to
who you are when you come up to raise
that point to yourself in the privacy of
your mind and say maybe I'm wrong about
this that's a really powerful thing to
do and especially when you're somebody
who's thinking about uh topics that can
uh about systems that can destroy human
civilization or maybe help with flourish
so thank you thank you for being willing
to be wrong